these tomatoes are sold at weekly
farmers markets or over the Internet for
workers - Hector's this fruit and
vegetable farmer recently took over the
business she would like to buy more land
but the prices of increased tenfold in
just 20 years
hi Scottie will be these are prices that
the people who do this work can't afford
they can't get the capital together to
be able to buying and running this
farmland is just out of the question for
us loccent this is agriculture on a
whole other dimension in eastern Germany
there are businesses that own 5,000
hectares or more behind it our
agricultural funds and large family
holdings with headquarters in far-off
regions
[Music]
line Hajong supports traditional farming
and is worried he's an independent
farmer and director of the Brandenburg
Farmers Association when he bought his
land the prices were half of what they
are now his land may be worth more now
but it's getting difficult to buy new
land and lease it investors with no ties
to the region are on a buying spree and
that bothers him the development began
and actually worsened with a financial
crisis when investors bought land it
drove the prices up in one way we're at
an advantage because the value of our
assets increased but of course we don't
want to sell our assets we want to keep
farming here you me a list of the
investors names for each operation they
receive millions of euros in EU
subsidies among them are investment
funds international furniture retailers
and family holding companies no one from
the list wants to comment on camera but
one of them has told me that he owns
15,000 hectares that are worth 170
million euros for him this real estate
means security in case of another
financial crisis in Germany the vast
tracts of land are located in the
eastern part of the country but there
are also similar tracts in Poland and in
the Baltic countries
that's where socialist collective farms
like this one used to be DEET maluca has
also been offered good money for his 800
hectare cattle farm
he himself had taken it over from a
socialist collective
one time when we made an offer in 1992
that privatized this farm we had to show
proof that we had agricultural technical
training otherwise we wouldn't have got
it today I don't need to tell you what
counts only one thing counts
what's that money can you buy the farm
or not 25 percent of agricultural real
estate in eastern Germany is already in
the hands of corporations and companies
based elsewhere many farmers are very
angry because it always leads to people
with no ties to the region taking over
and services from somewhere else in
Germany coming in with containers and
technology and doing work there and then
leaving again there's no connection at
all to the people in the region another
good EU subsidies depend on the size of
the land so while major investors get
millions mejia not only gets 360 euros a
year she wishes the major landowners
would receive lesson grants and that the
local small holders would get more there
are no longer enough people who
understand this system and understand
agriculture and can do it and do it well
then we cannot ward off the major
investors then we have to leave the land
to them if no one is there who can deal
with it properly she hopes the German
government will give more incentive for
the country's regional farmers then she
could expand her business more easily
[Music]
you